bonjour à tous huawei s'apprête à sortir
trois nouveaux smartphones les
successeurs du pdis avec trois caméras à
l'arrière et ça dès le début 2018 et on
en parle
[Musique]
vous connaissez c'est un constructeur
chinois qui s'est lancé pour mission de
doubler apple et samsung au niveau des
smartphones alors on lui souhaite bon
courage leur smartphone sont connus pour
être d'une grande qualité un partenariat
pour la photo avec leica voyous et c'est
vraiment la marque s'est positionné sur
le haut de gamme avec des produits qui
sont vraiment bien sûr les produits
milieu de gamme et dans cette gamme vous
avez léonore qui appartiennent également
à huawei mais c'est vrai que pour les
produits haut de gamme il se démarque
énormément et en 2018 ça devrait
continuer avec trois nouveaux
smartphones avant de commencer par vous
les présenter je voulais m'excuser un
petit peu de noms défaut de
prononciation pour huawei j'ai tendance
à dire ouais ouais ça sonne mieux cccc
c'est plus joli à l'oreille ouais bon je
suis désolé je me suis fait prendre deux
trois fois dans les commentaires donc je
vais vraiment essayer de faire attention
huawei et pour pas trop écorché le nom
donc huawei s'annonce huawei s'apprête à
sortir trois nouveaux smartphones se
sont réalité les successeurs du pdis
alors on n'est pas sûr le père 11 mai il
ya un vrai pas qu'ils aient sauté c'est
le p 20 p 20 plus ep20 pro on a regardé
qu'elle est un peu la différence est la
particularité de chaque smartphone
qu'est ce que ces smartphones vont
apporter de neuf pourquoi un changement
de nom et tout ça tout ça il ya
énormément de choses à avoir au niveau
de ses produits alors pour l'instant
c'est un ce sont des produits qui ne
sont pas encore commercialisés il y
annoncer par huawei mais qui devrait
être annoncé très rapidement
probablement au mwc à barcelone fin
février début mars peut-être même en
exclu ocs à las vegas alors bon c'est un
petit peu moins sur le le csa mon avis
ça sera plutôt le mwc en tout cas je
vous invite à vous inscrire parce que
quoi qu'il en coûte quoi qu'il se passe
le csj serait donc si je les vois bien
évidemment on en reparlera tout de suite
le mwc se faire mon maximum pour y être
donc rester connectés et dans tous les
cas on en parle très rapidement avant
toute chose une question à vous poser
est ce que vous avez déjà des produits
de chez huawei est ce que vous les avez
essayé est ce que vous envisagez d'en
prendre en ce petit quelque chose qui
pourrait vous intéresser dites moi tout
ça parce que c'est vrai qu'on devait 18
la donne 26 peut être distribués au
niveau des smartphones la fin d'année
est un petit peu difficile pour apple
cause du scandale sur les smartphones
ralenti à cause des performances de
batterie samsung devrait faire une
plutôt bonne année en 2018 avec
notamment l'arrivée du samsung galaxy s
9 et probablement du galaxy mix très
clairement huawei va aussi frappé très
très très fort avec ces trois nouveaux
smartphones plus les autres qui
arriveront après plus la gamme au nord
donc il va y avoir quelque chose de
vraiment énorme j'aimerais bien avoir
votre avis là-dessus savoir ce que vous
en pensez donc je vous invite à mettre
tous en commentaire pour qu'on puisse en
discuter ensemble huawei p20 p20 plus
ep20 pro alors j'ai déniché les plans
sur internet des petites infos alors des
infos qui ne sont pas des infos vraiment
peu pertinente c'est vraiment des
rumeurs très très pertinente et je pense
que c'est réellement ce qui va se passer
tout a commencé sur le réseau social web
ou web os alors je ne connais pas la
prononciation exacte c'est un réseau
social chinois a service de
microblogging effectivement trois
croquis qui ont été sortis de ses futurs
smartphones le p 20 le pev un plus et le
p 20 pros et on apprend énormément de
choses et c'est super intéressant comme
d'habitude me direz vous j'ai fait mon
boulot j'ai potassé tout ça donc j'ai
mes notes donc excusez moi si j'ai des
foyers qui cognent dessus mais pas tout
appris par coeur vu les vidéos la une
par jour c'est j'ai pas le temps de tout
apprendre ce qu on apprend tout cas
c'est que c'est de gamme p20 va
effectivement succéder au p 10 pourquoi
passer du pdis au p 20 alors il ya un
réel intérêt stratégique c'est plus un
intérêt marketing qu'un réel intérêt en
terme de produit parce que moi voyez
comme je le disais veut vraiment
dégommer apple et samsung sur le marché
des smartphones donc pour le faire ils
ont besoin de proposer déjà d'excellents
produits et bien évidemment de marquer
les esprits énormément très rapidement
et très fort s'ils font comme les autres
p10 p 11 p 12 p 13 on va voir que c'est
une succession normal une évolution
annuelle de la gamme alors que là en
passant du pdis au p 20 ils montrent
qu'ils font vraiment un bon d'un futur
un bond vers l'avant et quand moreau ils
sont en avance sur les autres ça peut
paraître tout bête mais on est vraiment
sur un concept marketing fort en
d'autant plus que wayne est vraiment en
avance à l'intelligence artificielle
haut niveau ses smartphones
non tu as more fun
des éléments tangibles
[Musique]
ça va être encore plus le cas l'année
prochaine donc ils veulent vraiment se
positionné comme une marque leader une
marque qui innovent et qui innovent
d'ailleurs bien mieux que les autres en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il propose alors
qu'est ce qu'on apprend sans ces
nouveaux smartphones on apprend qu'on va
avoir à l'arrière de chaque appareil 3
capteur photo rien que ça 3 capteur
photo qui vous permettront de monter
jusqu'à 40 mégapixels et y avoir un zoom
hybride x 5 alors ça peut paraître
énorme comme ça quel est l'intérêt
d'avoir 40 mégapixels avoir du pixel
pour du pixel on peut se demander
effectivement quel intérêt mais en ayant
si vous voulez 40 maia pixels trois
capteurs un partenariat fort avec les
cas on voit très bien que huawei veut se
positionner comme un leader de la
photographie sur smartphone et à mon
avis et risquent vraiment d'y arriver
autant ça me saoule fait aussi
d'excellentes photos avec des capteurs
qui marche très bien une bonne ouverture
donc une bonne luminosité des images qui
sont très belles la web est vraiment
frappé hyper fort alors pour l'instant
bien évidemment on est sur la rumeur on
est sur le début mais on connaît la
qualité on connaît le travail donc à mon
avis serait pas surprenant qu'en 2018
mais sans vraiment super fort sur les
photophones vous devriez aussi retrouvé
une caméra celle fille de 24 mégapixels
si vous avez une belle ouverture ça
risque vraiment de faire le job du coup
des photos plus lumineuse en faible
luminosité beaucoup moins de bruit et
des belles qualités d'image du zoom
optique on va pouvoir aller chercher
directement dans la photo sans forcément
avoir un zoom numérique qui va venir
bouffer du pixel toute façon sur de 40
milliards pixels normalement à 3
s'inquiéter par contre c'est super
intéressant c'est l'emplacement des
capteurs photos sur le pv vous les avez
à l'horizontale 1 2 3 sur le pépin plus
vous les avez à la verticale mais sur un
côté de l'appareil et sur le pépin pro
vous les avez au centre de l'appareil
autre changement entre les appareils
c'est le lecteur d'empreintes digitales
sur le p 20 bp 20 plus vous les avez en
bas de l'écran sur la face avant sur le
pépin pro vous l'avez au milieu à
l'arrière huawei va aussi développer
énormément l'intelligence artificielle
et notamment pour les photos c'est
quelque chose qui met vraiment en avant
ils ont déjà mis en avant à la fin de
l'année dernière c'est l'intelligence
artificielle pour la reconnaissance de
scène lorsqu'on va prendre par exemple
en photo un plat de la nourriture
l'intelligence artificielle reconnaître
axe un plat et optimisera la gamme de
couleurs la lumière le cliché en règle
générale pour valoriser par rapport à
ses connaissances pareil ça capable de
reconnaître un chien ce que prendra
photo reconnaître un chat reconnaître un
paysage donc vous aurez des photos plus
optimisée grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle côté processeur le pvp 20
plus devrait avoir un kirin 970 c'est
déjà un processeur pour trouve déjà chez
huawei par contre le pépin pro devrait
avoir le keirin 975 qui est légèrement
plus puissant que son prédécesseur mais
on va aller un peu plus loin en terme de
performance il faut savoir que ces
modèles devraient avoir en tout cas tous
les trois si giga de ram et 64 giga de
stockage 64 giga bien sûr qu'on pourra
étendre à l'aide d'une carte micro sd
côté écran sur le paiement ep20 plus on
devrait retrouver les mêmes dimensions
d'écran probablement du full hd et sur
le peu d'impôts on devrait avoir un
écran 5 7 pouces quad hd 2560 par 1940
pixels horatio 18/9 un plus grand écran
avec une encoche en rond comme on peut
le retrouver sur l'iphone 10 allant une
encoche un peu plus petite que celle qui
est disponible sur l'iphone dit on peut
très bien imaginer d'avoir de la
reconnaissance faciale en trois
dimensions ça c'est aussi une sur
laquelle huawei a communiqué l'année
dernière cette fameuse reconnaissance
faciale en trois dimensions un peu comme
fayçal dit s'il voulait tout simplement
et on devrait également trouver une
batterie de 4000 milliampères heures
donc un smartphone avec des performances
peu plus boosté par rapport à ce qu'on
trouvait avant surtout de bien
meilleures photos de bien meilleure
qualité et une excellente auto de lui
avec cette batterie de 4000 millan paire
eur voilà tout ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sans ces trois futurs
smartphones de huawei et 20 paix valent
plus p20 pro qui devrait sortir au
deuxième trimestre 2000 18 est ce que
ces smartphones pourrait vous intéresser
oui non à quel prix à mon avis elle
souhaite aussi un peu cher alors
forcément moins cher que la concurrence
moins cher que apple et son iphone 10 en
tout cas aux prix annoncés dans sa
sortie - sierre probablement que le
galaxy s 9 quoique on est en trop à peu
près dans les mêmes prix on est vraiment
sur des produits haut de gamme qui vont
forcément coûter plus cher à la
fabrication est forcément une
répercussion son client au consommateur
final est plus chère à l'achat dites moi
tout ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire en commentaire plusieurs
virages je bafouille je vous invite à
laisser des jolies pousse bien
évidemment à vous abonner parce qu'on a
toujours parlé plus de teck on saura
d'ici quelques jours au csa las vegas où
on va aller voir toutes les nouvelles
tendances avec croustillant donc rester
connectés et je pense qu'on va vraiment
se faire plaisir ça va être un truc de
dingue je vous remercie d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo je vous dis à très bientôt
d'ici là soyez ça je vous embrasse et
portez vous bien ciao
[Musique]